senator Marsha Blackburn senator
congratulations you won by a big margin
in the end there was some polls at one
point that had your race close you ran
away with it we're very happy we
supported your candidacy where is the
Senate on this where a lot of the
insanity in the house of Nancy Pelosi
and some of these more radical members
it's not going anywhere
so where is the Senate specifically on
standing up for secure borders for the
country
I think leader McConnell has said it
well it has to whatever comes to the
Senate has to include border funding and
the reason for that Sean is when you
look at what the president is asking for
five billion dollars that is 1/10 of 1%
of the budget and we are required to
protect the country to provide for the
common defense and this is a part
protecting that sovereignty is a part of
protecting the country and it is
absolutely outrageous that the Democrats
are not coming to the table they're
refusing to negotiate they do not want
to make a deal and I will tell you this
if I were someone with a dreamer in my
family I would be very upset with the
Democrats right now because that path to
legalization that they have often said
is what they want that is something on
the table and you are hearing Nancy
Pelosi say not one dollar not any money
and although she offered a dollar you
know we've had many people murdered by
illegal immigrants and as the sheriff on
this program out in California mentioned
this week that he believes that officers
saying what happened to him because the
person responsible for that murder was
in the criminal justice system outside
of being in this country illegally I had
ice been allowed to do their job they
would have deported this individual at
what point when drugs pour into the
country and human trafficking continues
and gang members potential
terrorists and those that commit violent
crimes when we don't stop them and you
have cities and states aiding and
abetting them by not turning them over
to ice do they bear responsibility for
the future actions of those criminal
aliens well yes and what you're seeing
is that because we have this open border
you have every town a border town and
every state a border state and these
gangs and drug traffickers human
traffickers sex traffickers are coming
to a community near you and they're all
across our country and people know that
and law enforcement knows that this is
why you have our Border Patrol and law
enforcement saying secure that border we
need a wall we need to have a barrier
because that will help keep people from
coming in it will serve as a way to stop
the traffickers and I you know when you
talk to angel moms in individuals that
have lost their children are their
spouses or loved ones to these illegal
aliens many of them criminal illegal
aliens that should have been deported it
is heartbreaking and Tennesseans want to
see the border secured well I got to
tell you at some point they bear some of
the responsibility by not enforcing the
laws senator great to have you back in
your new capacity congratulations on a
big victory much needed voice in the
Senate